my ADHD wasn't diagnosed until I was an
adult and probably like many of us was
told that the liabilities that come with
ADHD were weaknesses why can't you just
focus you know why can't you sit still
um it really upsets me that we call it a
deficit in the disorder we have
characteristics and attributes that make
us who we are and in some contexts those
things are weaknesses and in some
contexts those things are strengths and
so yes ADHD does come with liability
absolutely in some contexts it's a
struggle for me to get my work done
absolutely but in some contexts it is an
absolute superpower I have crazy
creativity where my mind can operate
like a pinball machine where I can see
patterns can connect dots that most
people can't see or can do it a lot
quicker than a lot of people so why
can't we tell children that they have
hyper Focus that occasionally comes with
distractibility as opposed to telling
kids that they have a deficit in the
disorder that if you're lucky you'll
figure out the superpower I want us to
teach kids about the superpower